while you were distracted by inflation
in Ukraine China and Russia have been
secretly stockpiling gold at an
unprecedented rate is China's
stockpiling gold as the world gold
Council has reported a sharp rise in
Gold purchases by the central banks
around the world the council's November
report states that central banks bought
over
399 tons of gold between July and
September this year why because they are
preparing for something massive and
Vladimir Putin just unveiled their plan
to the world a new Global Reserve
currency a currency that they want to
replace the dollar worth as the new
Reserve currency of the world well
analysts continue to speculate on the
implications of an international Reserve
currency planned by Russia and China if
China and Russia managed to pull us off
it will change everything America will
no longer be the global superpower
anymore it would be cataclysmic to the
US economy and it would usher in a new
era a new world order a new world order
where China and Russia will be be the
ones calling the shots not America and
it's not as if their plane is even that
far-fetched after World War II America
did almost the exact same thing where
they single-handedly strong armed the
world into accepting the dollar as the
new Global Reserve but that was close to
around 80 years ago today America is not
in as strong of a position to strong arm
the world today America is in the
decline it's racked up an impossible
amount of debts it's printed the dollar
into almost non-existence the money
printing during covet has left even the
common men wondering how long the music
can last and just like every other
currency in history is not a matter of
if the dollar will go to zero but when
the US dollar is on the last one percent
of its purchasing power it's honest last
dying breath this last dying breath
could last a few years or a few decades
no one knows for sure but all signs
point to something big happening in the
next few years but you don't have to
look at the grass and illness if you
live in America you can just feel it in
the air the future feels Bleak every
year seems to get crazier than the last
our trusting government is added all
Time Low it feels like we're slowly
headed towards a waterfall and Vladimir
poon and Xi Jinping are trying their
damn this to cash in on this once in a
lifetime opportunity if this plan works
China and Russia will become invincible
in America all that power it's been
enjoying for decades it will be Stripped
Away by force this is the first video in
a two-part series on the upcoming new
world order and to understand it we have
to take a trip back to the end of World
War II
foreign
politics is scary and all but you know
what else is scary premature ejaculation
finishing too fast in bed which 30
percent of you probably have or even
worse erectile dysfunction not being
able to get it up which half of you
might have so if you want better sex
this year you should definitely get
treated but going to a doctor's office
and admitting that you can't get it up
is a big hassle but lucky for you that
is where Roman comes in Roman is the
digital health clinic for men Roman lets
you consult with U.S licensed Healthcare
Providers it allows you to get
personalized treatment and you can even
get prescription medication shipped
discreetly right to your door when
appropriate it's just a super simple
digital experience from the comfort of
your own home Roman even offers discreet
wipes to help you last four times longer
in bed no prescription needed and Roman
goes much further than just treating
premature ejaculation or Ed you can go
to them for hair loss skin treatment and
so much more so say goodbye to long wait
times awkward in-person visits and the
stress of not being able to take care of
your health because for Roman you get
the care you need when you need it use
my unique link below or go to ro.co
jakesham for 20 off your first order
today as rl.co for 20 off your order
thanks to Roman for sponsoring this
video
at brettonwood New Hampshire delegates
from 44 Allied and Associate countries
arrived for the opening of the United
Nations monetary and financial
conference
invited by President Roosevelt to the
first Major World Financial meeting
since the London Conference of 1933 to
be discussed our plans for the
stabilization of world currencies all
agreements must be ratified by the
governing bodies of the Nations involved
before becoming effective the American
dollar has been the reserve currency of
the world ever since the Bretton Woods
conference in 1944. these meetings are
designed to promote trade in the
post-war world and to create a
foundation for lasting peace after World
War II America had the strongest
military and held the most gold so it
made sense for the gold-backed dollar to
become the currency that all other
countries base the value of their
currencies on the strength of a nation's
currency is based on the strength of
that nation's economy and the American
economy is by far the strongest in the
world and that gave America an insane
Advantage being the global Reserve met
America to secretly print as much money
as it wanted without the dollar ever
losing value and it didn't take long for
that ability to go to America's head
which ultimately led to the collapse of
the Bretton Woods system in 1971. we
must protect the position of the
American dollar I have directed the
Secretary of the Treasury to take the
action necessary to defend the dollar
against the speculators I have directed
secretary Conley to suspend temporarily
the convertibility of the dollar into
gold or other Reserve assets and in the
best interests of the United States this
left America with no way to force the
world into using the dollar as the
reserve if no one needed gold to give
their money value anymore no one would
need America's dollars or the gold by
which it was backed if America wanted
the dollar to stay Almighty it would
have to figure out a way to force the
world to keep using it enter the petrol
dollar see back in 1973 things were not
going well between America and the oil
rich countries Middle East in the space
of just a few months these oil countries
pretty much quadrupled oil prices which
led to a crazy fuel shortage All Over
America as we've mentioned before on
this channel which you should definitely
subscribe to oil is the lifeblood of an
Empire a small oil shortage can bring an
Empire like the US to its nice think
about it without oil factories will shut
down production collapses people can't
try the work so it's no wonder why
America has been willing to wage war in
the name of oil and it's also no wonder
why during this oil crisis America had
to do whatever it took to ensure that
they would never be at the whim of these
hostile oil countries ever again so in
1974 America's new treasury secretary a
guy named William Simon was sent to make
a deal with Saudi Arabia one of the
biggest oil producers in the world his
proposal Saudi Arabia makes a new law
that says it will only sell oil in US
Dollars no matter who is trying to buy
oil from them and in exchange America
will provide the kingdom with all the
military training weapons and modern
infrastructure that it could dream of it
was a win-win situation because Saudi
Arabia was one of the biggest oil
producers them selling oil and dollars
for Force other countries to have to buy
dollars in order to buy oil from Saudi
Arabia which would make other oil
countries have to sell their oil in
dollars if they wanted to compete and
boom just like that the world would be
reliant on dollars but it doesn't stop
there since America was in control of
the money printer whenever it needed
more oil it could just print more
dollars which meant that thanks to this
deal with Saudi Arabia it would never
face an oil shortage again it's hard to
put into words how vital this was to
America's global domination this allowed
America to practically get free oil
because all they had to do was print
more dollars and since this forced the
world to trade in dollars it meant that
whenever America printed more money the
rest of the world would have to bear the
blood of their dollars getting weaker
Saudi Arabia would also win in this
arrangement from being the main seller
of oil to America and on top of that
they would have the most powerful
country in the world the most powerful
military in the world in their Corner
their safety and their future was now
guaranteed and no one will ever dare
touch them and boom just like that an
Unholy Alliance was cemented between
America and a kingdom with a lot of
Human Rights problems the Petron dollar
became America's superpower a superpower
that it would protect at any cost
when saddaf Hussein announced that Iraq
would start selling oil in Euros instead
of dollars guess what happened America
invaded them in an operation ironically
called operation Iraqi Freedom America
was in search of weapons of mass
destruction and although wmds were never
found conveniently three months later
the country was back to selling oil in
dollars but the U.S invasion of 2003 set
the country's oil industry safely back
into dollar denomination when Hugo
Chavez of Venezuela said he was going to
do the same thing stop selling oil in
dollars the US bet a coup against Santa
ultimately failed and when Muammar
Gaddafi of Libya suggested that all
Muslim and African nations buy oil from
Libya using gold instead of dollars and
that they were going to launch a new
gold-back currency well America started
a civil war that led to Gaddafi being
executed by U.S backed rebels in 2011.
this is an incredibly gruesome scene
these are completely destroyed Vehicles
everywhere I'm looking now is littered
with bodies and they're talking about
the secret burial of Gaddafi but here is
where those who are with him on Thursday
morning died
next in between oil and the dollar is
what kept the dollar at the top of the
food chain for nearly half a century
it's what allowed America to print a
psychotic amount of money during coven
and still be left standing somehow and
every time some small insignificant
country would try to stand up against
the petrol dollar America would crush
them back into submission but this time
is difference this time it's not some
weak and significant country threatening
the petrol dollar this time is China and
Russia and unlike their previous enemies
China and Russia aren't scared by
sanctions or the threat of invasion
which means this time they might
actually have a shot at dethroning the
dollar once and for all
foreign
[Music]
Russia have been trying to get out from
under the Dollar's influence for decades
now but as long as the dollar is the
global Reserve that is kind of
impossible almost every Financial system
in the world is based on the dollar most
of China and Russia's imports and
exports are paid for in dollars and even
though they hate to admit it their own
economies heavily rely on the dollar but
if Russia and China could find a way to
replace the dollar as their own Reserve
if they could find a way to convince a
decent amount of other countries to do
the same they would be out from under
America's control forever and trying to
find a replacement for the dollar isn't
exactly a new thing for these two rumors
have been circling for years about the
possibility of Russia and China creating
a new digital currency backed by gold in
2015 China even created its own
alternative to Swift which is what most
countries use the transfer money
internationally but no one believed that
they would actually be able to pull it
off that was until earlier this year
when Russia and China suddenly started
buying up a lot more gold than usual and
unlike the dollar which is now backed by
debts and by everyone's faith in the U.S
government China and Russia want to
create a new Reserve currency based on
gold just like the dollar used to be
before 1971. this would give the
currency actual real value it would give
people a reason to trust and use this
new currency because at least
theoretically they wouldn't be able to
print more of it on the fly so China and
Russia's recent interest in buying gold
is a pretty good sign that something is
happening officially Russia and China
have the sixth and seventh largest
stockpiles of gold right behind America
Germany the IMF Italy and France but the
official numbers are a little deceiving
see if you're planning on threatening
the Petro dollar which has a track
record of ending in either deaf or
Invasion you're not going to be bragging
about your gold stockpiles prematurely
you're going to collect the gold quietly
and announce your plans when the time is
right and that's exactly what Russia and
China have been doing officially China
has just under 2 000 tons of gold in
reserve that's nothing compared to
America's over 8 000 tons rights but
what about China's unofficial reserves
for the past 10 years China has been
producing 15 of all the gold Med the
world or at least 6 800 tons and more
than half of all of China's gold
production is state owned meaning the
Chinese government is in Direct Control
of at least half of that six thousand
eight hundred tons for the past 10 years
and you still expect us to believe that
China's gold reserves are just under 2
000 tons in total not stupid you know
especially when China is known to lie
about numbers all the time and what
about gold Imports since the year 2000
more than 6 700 tons of gold have been
imported into China just through Hong
Kong alone and thus not even including
the gold imported through other hubs
like Dubai in Switzerland and since the
start of this year these numbers have
only gone up in October 2022 Switzerland
exported over 80 tons of gold with 4.4
billion dollars to Mainland China still
believes China's gold reserves are as
low as they say they are and Russia
isn't far behind Russia has been on a
gold buying spree ever since it got
slapped with sanctions for invading
Crimea in 2014 and Russia recently
started expanding its gold mining
operations all over Africa to increase
their supply for Millennia Sudan has
produced some of the most sought after
gold in the world
and Putin's private Army the notorious
paramilitary group Wagner knows it
Wagner's tentacles stretch right across
Africa we've discovered some of its most
notorious operatives are working on
Sudan so even though it's safe to say
Russia alone doesn't have more gold than
America China definitely might and
together their goverse could be a
serious threat to the dominance of the
dollar the Chinese Finance ministers
previously announced that their
intention is to have more gold than the
US so the U.S purportedly has 8 000 tons
which a lot of people have questioned
because there hasn't been an audit done
since the 1950s but let's assume they do
have a thousand tons China buys its gold
Through The Sovereign wealth fund and is
currently the number one gold producer
in the world but any of the gold that's
produced by China is kept in China
doesn't go outside of China so it
doesn't answer the goal Market same
thing happens for Russia and Russia I
think is the number two or three gold
producer they're keeping all their gold
but what China does is they buy the gold
and The Sovereign wealth fund and that
doesn't report anything to anybody and
the Central Bank reportedly only has
1600 tons now many people think that
China already has well in excess of 6
000 tons in The Sovereign wealth fund
and China really isn't going to make an
announcement that they have more gold to
the U.S until they feel the time is
right it's just one problem creating a
new Reserve currency is going to take
more than just two countries it's called
a global Reserve currency for a reason
which means if China and Russia want to
Dethrone the dollar they would have to
get a whole bunch of other countries to
join them which is a lot easier said
than done getting the world of switch
Reserve currencies is kind of like
trying to get America to switch to the
metric system even though the metric
system is better it is next to
Impossible the old way of doing things
has a stickiness in them and it takes a
very dramatic event to make change the
last event to do that was World War II
remember the petrol dollar the deal with
Saudi Arabia that forced nearly all oil
rich countries in the world to sell
their oil in dollars the deal that
cemented the dollar to State the global
Reserve after America went off the gold
standard yeah well as long as that deal
stays in place creating a new Reserve
currency would be nearly impossible how
could Russia and China expect anyone to
adopt a new Reserve currency if they
couldn't even buy oil with it oil is
still the lifeblood of every country so
there's no way anyone would switch to a
new Reserve currency if it meant they
couldn't buy oil anymore unless unless
China and Russia find a way to sabotage
that relationship between America and
Saudi Arabia if they could somehow
convince Saudi Arabia to leave that deal
with America and stop selling their oil
in dollars it would change everything it
would undo everything and it would mean
the end of America's reign
and guess what Saudi Arabia is looking
to do just that they have a great desire
and they are not the only country that
is finding the brics family or formation
attractive because of what brics stands
for and no mainstream Western news
outlets are reporting on it next time on
Jake Tran President Biden is bashing
Saudi Arabia that's a big mistake the
U.S is furious about opec's decision to
cut oil production President Joe Biden
has spoken of reevaluating relations
with Riyadh American lawmakers want to
stop supplying weapons to Saudi Arabia
relations between Saudi Arabia and the
United States have been strained of late
that after OPEC plus decided to slash
oil production and Washington is not
held back in its rebuke of the Kingdom
tensions between America and Saudi
Arabia escalating this week with the
White House accusing the Saudis of quote
coercing its allies to cut oil
production inside with Russia and here's
another battle that the West is fighting
a battle of narratives a battle to win
new allies only that it is failing
miserably at this first it refuses to
ramp up oil production for the European
Union and now it was wants to be a part
of bricks
[Music]